jamais vu résidents cinquième république
continue luc au bout et bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous remercie d'avoir plein
d'arguments un médecin à table oui moi
je suis prêt à débattre voyez rien n'est
pas beaucoup pourquoi j'ai pas
par oxydation
qui fait
si vous
c'est parce qu'on le voudrait mais
derrière que ce soit l'enfer benalla
mcs si molière votre petit copain la
java signataires j'allais jouer vous ça
se mélange quand même beaucoup dans la
tête ah oui mais il ya beaucoup
d'arguments que je le remplace c'est un
des arguments
et détruit tous les sens alors ça c'est
la première partie de la vidéo dans une
seconde vidéo dans ton ce même homme
qualifié de président de termes très peu
élogieux regard et la d league vous êtes
manipulateur et vous êtes moteur
jamais je n'ai voté marine données
c'est quoi les faits on a été pris pour
des moins que rien des clients
oui oui vous êtes à dire quoi quel est
le cas les choses sur lesquelles
quelle richesse lesquels reflètent pas
vous avez à l'hôpital mais vous êtes
fous qui fonde
mon médecin traitant il a été radié
monte aux antilles style a été rallié
dans le village
car à 10 par mois annoncé c'est pas vous
qui a pris ses décisions concrètes à
l'équipe se vaccine voulait pas ce maxi
misogyne rendez vous les remettez offert
les ordres qui les énerve lycée du gros
bah oui c'est lui qui a donné les autres
c'est un longue échange un sami vous
étiez c'est vous qui avez fait c'est
vrai micro qu'on voit comme ça j'étais
avec le téléphone ces mots tranchants
comme ça un peu compliqué alors ça me
c'est incroyable ce que l'échangé est
très très long qu'est ce qui s'est passé
en fait on était dans une séquence où le
président tout cas le candidat macron
justement faisait une déambulation à
strasbourg à mulhouse et dans cette
petite ville d'ailleurs très charmant de
qui s'appelle châtenois et il fait cette
déambulation ça se passe plutôt bien il
fait beaucoup de celles fils et répond à
des questions il ya des échanges qui
sont parfois assez vifs assez musclé
mais là en fait il ya ce monsieur qui
arrive sur la gauche et qui voulait
absolument parler au président qui
insiste et qui arrive face au président
de la république qui le laisse passer la
sécurité de l'espace et ou pas oui bien
sûr en fait lors de ses déambulations la
sécurité laisse toujours passer les
personnes qui veulent interpeller
président et ça il ya des choses qui ont
aidé ni qui seront assez fausse là
dessus c'est à dire que il ya forcément
des militants la république en marche
qui sont là mais aussi beaucoup de
badauds ça m'a interpellé le président
vous allez sur un mauvais déplacement
car vous êtes contrôlés vous êtes
fouillé mais vous pouvez aller au
contact en tout cas pendant la campagne
et donc c'est vrai que moi ça fait
quatre ans que je suis emmanuel macron
que je peux vous les lisez et j'ai
rarement vu en fait une invective aussi
violente aussi aussi violentes s'étaient
presque chirurgicale en fait il est tout
de suite allé sur la sémantique vraiment
très très violente et emmanuel macron
qui justement avant cette séquence
sortait de bain de foule de sel fils une
séquence plutôt positive en fait il a
été presque sidérés il était un peu ko
debout et c'est pour ça que en fait la
deuxième vidéo que vous avez montré
c'est le premier moment et on le voit un
peu un peu un peu sidérée un peu mais ça
a démarré vers la fin en fait voilà
c'est ça d'accord et est du coup là je
me suis dit donc moi j'avais commencé à
filmer juste avant ma chute je sortais
qui pouvait se passer quelque chose et
c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là quand je
tourne cette séquence je me dis ah oui
là je vais pas je tiens quand même
séquence qui fait beaucoup parler alors
j'hibernais de penser qu'on peut on peut
interpeller comme ça le président
absolument nos candidats ou le président
les deux âmes et franchement les deux et
je trouve qu emmanuel macron s'en sort
bien mais c'est comme un boxeur qui
descendent dans l'arène vous avez vous
parlé de chaos c'est exactement ça on
lui a reproché de pas aller au combat de
fuir ben là il est dans l'arène et je
trouve très bien qu'ils laissent le la
personne s'est exprimée en longueur y
répond point par point bon faut pas être
dupe ça le sert emmanuel macron parce
qu'on lui avait tellement reproché
d'être le sphinx dans sa tour d'ivoire
que là il est face à face aux gens et
moi je dis bravo à cette personne passe
est très courageux quand même parce
qu'il faut le faire à l'oreille il a dit
qu'il a découvert y en a et l'organe
avait en plus une gauche qui reconnut
dieu ex tétouan
reconnu frérot delphine qui dit non non
je pense qu'on n'a pas droit de parler
un président comme ça mais en même temps
le président n'a pas le droit de nous
parler de la même manière je veux dire
voilà emmerder emmerder les français
c'est dans le même registre donc j'ai
envie de vous emmerder vous êtes nuls en
fait on on récolte ce qu'on sème et moi
je trouve que là aussi il ya un peu une
condescendance dans cet extrait parce
que vous êtes nuls c'est chez moi en
alsace j'ai pas autrement dit excuse moi
ce sont des ce sont des personnes qui
ont l'accent alsacien voilà qui qui qui
parle bas qui n'ont pas la rhétorique et
l'art oratoire et puis on a un président
qui s'est très très bien parler français
qui est là qui répond bar dites moi
qu'est ce que vous pensez exactement
dites moi vos explications des
argumentaires pas forcément le cas il
n'avait pas la liste il a parlé avec le
coeur donc là aussi en fait ya un
décalage de un problème de communication
je pense entre ce candidat et les
français parce qu'on n'est pas sur un
plan humain hyper positif j'attends que
saint bernard 6 de démocratie puisque
d'abord lui a parlé de choses de très
agressive il a dit mais je vous respecte
tout ce que vous dites il a été quand
même incroyable mois imaginer un mec
dans la rue ils vous disent ah tu casses
la gueule août une fois prenez pas la
wii n'ont pas précisé si moi je suis
président c'est à dire je m'embrouille
toutes les minutes
débile qui disent qu'on est en dictature
là c'est un bel exemple pour montel a
décroît la démocratie française s'est
désolé alors dit ce qu'on veut au
président est là en l'occurrence c'est
le candidat que vous comprenez qu'on
puisse interpeller comme ça très bien et
d'ailleurs le service de sécurité il l'a
dit permet aux gens de passer alors que
d'autres bars et quand on voyait les
mecs un peu excité parce que ça se voit
et ce qu'il a dit il peut il a eu raison
de dire ce qu'ils voulaient mais je
trouve ça bien l'objectif de l'exercice
c'est vraiment allées dallées d'aller à
la rencontre c'est le risque aussi pour
vaincre il faut convaincre c'est ce
qu'on dit ces savants mais là moi j'ai
senti chez cette personne en fait une
accumulation de ressentiment justement
sur sur ces dernières années et il se
retrouve devant le président c'est son
moment et c'est emmanuel macron il va
pas venir tout là bien sûr rien à chaque
mois je pense que là c'est la seule fo
et pourrait où il pouvait comme ça le
l'interpeller et donc ça sort c'était
vraiment un cri du coeur et certains
parlent de mise ancien moi c'est pas du
tout en tout cas ce que j'ai alors
toutes les images qu'on voit c'est de
vous ah bon toutes les images c'est vous
oui oui oui tout en fait j'essaie
c'était une vidéo en deux parties et
sessegnon
et les achète les images
non je suis je suis de ma réaction c'est
ça il est sur les réseaux de façon on ne
peut reprendre les images quelques
personnes qui les ont inscrits n'est
qu'ils ont diffusé c'est un peu demandé
l'autorisation mais bon ça c'est
d'accord - spartak
et tu fais pas ça pour l'argent tu as
bien raison dans l'air con et dire on
peut pas citer les missions
c'est comme ça que l'accord avait quand
même bien dans le pays font assez comme
ça je savais qu est ce qui s'est passé
après cet échange avec le président il
en fait on était plusieurs confrères sur
sur place et on a tous chercher ce
monsieur a bien su aimerait trouver
on est sûr c'est un vrai gars
de party il est parti et c'est vrai que
l'on voulait tous c'est ce qui se passe
généralement quand il ya cette réaction
l'a ensuite on va savoir il a voté quel
est son profil pourquoi est ce que les
interpellés de cette façon là et on l'a
pas trouvé voilà j'étais avec mes
confrères de d d autres chaînes de télé
est bon je pense que si on va à
châtenois et qu'on mène l enquête on
pouvoir va le retrouver mais mais
c'était vraiment un échange vif mais
intéressant j'ai trouvé que c'était çà
çà çà pouvait traduire quelque chose non
mais dans votre documentaire et enfin
votre reportage il vit qui votent marine
le pen oui il a voté pour emmanuel
macron 2007 et là il a changé sa vie
votre apport il connaît son profil
c'était on connaît son profil c'était
emmanuel macron 2017 et puis ensuite un
déçu qui passe qui fait anti anti mac on
appelle moi j'aime quand ça s'invective
j'aime quand il ya ces mots-là à partir
du moment où on reste dans une certaine
limite je trouve que c'est agréable vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'on est en manque
de débat on n'a pas eu de présidentielle
on à sa campagne on n'a pas eu de débat
là on a donc on a besoin de ça on a
besoin ces scènes là maintenant je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il
serait pas mieux ici franchement mieux
ici avec comme ça on aura entendu la
question en entier il aurait pu répondre
en entier y aurait pas le jeune homme en
train de filmer avec son portable sami
heureusement qu'il était là
mais dire c'est que c'est quand même
plus plat il est bien avec les gens et
inquiète par eh bien il serait bien ici
mais il est bien aussi de faire ça je
peux bien sûr bonsoir c'est
moi d'abord g je suis content
d'apprendre que on a le droit d'aller à
parler au président comme ça et je mords
ça c'est très bien pour la démocratie
quand la diva campagne président surtout
en campagne moi je pense est verrouillé
les gens étaient choisis il fallait
crier mâcon président donc la cdu
content de l'apprendre et après ce que
monsieur moi il m'a fait du bien parce
qu il a envoyé le message de plein de
france est plein de français qui ont été
blessés par la politique de mâcon depuis
ses 5 ans et je trouve qu'il s'est super
bien débrouillé il n'a pas la sémantique
il parle pas il parle avec ces mots
monsieur macron lui tient le bras un
moment donné peut-être pour l'intimider
c'est que ça laisse pechoux saura tout
intimidé il ya une prise demain il ya
une liste d'actifs mais on lui demande
pas d'être ça aurait pu imprimer de
monsieur bah oui on sait nuire et
continue il dit ce qu'il adviendra si je
pourrai dit monsieur macron 2010 un
sommet dans votre tête effectivement
donnez moi des arguments et ben il lui
donne et lui dit l'hôpital il n'est pas
certain a dit ben alla donc j'ai adoré
et ce monsieur j'ai l'impression que il
a représenté plein de gens quand il a
fait ça même avec sa sémantique même
avec les mots on a tout compris mais moi
je vous dis bravo monsieur c'est très
bien et bravo elle m'a pas tu peux lui
dire une dernière fois
emmanuel macron d'aller voir les gens
parce que c'est bien de faire des
émissions plateau mais c'est bien de
certains outils parce que là il voit
vraiment donc c'est dans des régions
hostiles
pour samy qui suit ça de près a beaucoup
reproché à emmanuel macron avant la
campagne d'aller dans des endroits où il
choisissait les gens qui intervenait
auprès de lui ça lui était reproché
est-ce que là c'est lui même qui a passé
la consigne laisser passer tout le monde
même si vous sentez que quelqu'un peut
déborder je veux lui parler et ses deux
compagnes la campagne du premier tour
c'est vrai qu'il était sur des terrains
qui était acquis à la république aux
marches et il s'est dit je pense en tout
cas si l'entourage qui nous expliquent
comme ça que pour convaincre les gens il
faut aller sur des terrains qui vous
sont un peu hostile convainquent d un
électorat par exemple dans le bon test
c'est marine le pen qui arrive en tête à
mulhouse c'était à strasbourg c'était
mélenchon est donc pour expliquer sa
réforme des retraites à 65 ans il faut
qu'il soit interpellé silva dans un
village ou dans une ville qui est bien
est acquis à sa cause et avec les gens
mais rien n'est fait que de celle ci
qu'il pourra pas expliqué sa bo xi une
stratégie politique ça marche ça marche
pas ça on verra c'est pas à moi de dire
moi je reporte que l'effet que constate
sur place mais voilà c'est ça en tout
cas la stratégie de la république en
marche
oui moi je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse
être choqué par cette séquence dire
puisque ce monsieur ne manque pas de
respect emmanuel macron sur le fond et
sur la forme il ne l'insulté pas il ne
s'en prend pas à lui physiquement je
trouve qu'ils manuel macouin et très bon
effectivement parce qu'il prend le temps
de parler avec lui après sur le fond je
suis désolé mais nul répond pas du tout
et comme d'habitude ils sont dans la
facilité d quelqu'un qui le pousse dans
ses retranchements vous êtes un fou vous
êtes un complotiste vous dites n'importe
quoi vous mélangez tout non ils
salissent ainsi il a dit les mélanges et
à dire vous mélangez tout vous est
l'ange dans votre tête et voilà ça se
mélange avec un prix modique on il a dit
vous êtes fou n'est pas fou il lui dit
concrètement il ya des gens qui ont
perdu leur emploi à cause du passé ni
terre et là il répond avec vous êtes
fous ils fuient et la différence entre
ça et une émission en plateau avec un
débat c'est que là il peut partir quand
il veut en plateau il doit répondre aux
français et c'est pour ça qu'il a peur
de débattre au choc sur le fond il
répond pas bien tu ne peux pas dire
qu'il a peur d'aller vers l'avant qui va
quand même ça au devant des français
depuis une semaine et il va continuer
encore mais ne veut pas dire qu'il n'est
pas désirable c'est plus difficile
d'être là bas bah non en général non sur
un plateau moi là-bas 15,9 et tout est à
tort on a le temps de d'exposer que ce
soit toi ou un ordre là c'est très
différent en se passant dans la rue tu
es nul etc il faut l'encaisser plein
cours par un animateur qui cadre là il
envoie un de ses conseillers
non c'est trop facile des mâles bahri
ben non